and dear fellow scholars this is two
minute papers with károly Jean IFA here
what is an acoustic filter well it is an
arbitrarily shaped object that takes a
sound as an input and outputs a
different sound
these filters have some really amazing
applications that you'll hear about in a
minute in this work a novel technique is
proposed to automatically design such
filters it works by building an
arbitrarily shaped object as a set of
connected tiny resonators and chooses
appropriate sizes and setups for each of
these elements to satisfy a prescribed
set of acoustic properties instead of
resorting to a lengthy and flimsy
trial-and-error phase we can use physics
to simulate what would happen if we were
to use a given arrangement in reality
again one of those works that have a
deep connection to the real world around
us absolutely amazing the goal can be to
eliminate the peaks of the sound of a
car horn or an airplane engine and we
can achieve this objective by means of
optimization the proposed applications
we can divide into three main categories
the first is identifying and filtering
noise attenuation components for a
prescribed application to which we can
also refer to as muffler design in
simpler words we are interested in
filtering or muffling the peaks of a
known signal designing such objects is
typically up to trial and error and in
this case it is even harder because we
are interested in a wider variety of
shaped choices other than exhaust pipes
and tubes that are typically used in the
industry
but this unoptimized muffler the three
peaks are not suppressed now we replace
the muffler with an optimized one the
three peaks are more suppress another
application from muffler designs
acoustic your must we may adapters allow
for switching between acoustic filters
the first pair of earmuffs is optimized
reduce engine cranking oils we can see a
three-piece are now suppressed for Laura
Samba second designing musical
instruments is hard
and unless we design them around
achieving a given acoustic response will
likely end up within harmonious
gibberish and this method also supports
designing musical instruments with hmm
well non conventional shapes
well this is as non-conventional as it
gets I'm afraid and also that is about
the most harmonious sound I've heard
coming out of the rear end of a hippo
and third this work opens up the
possibility of making hollow objects
that are easy to identify by means of
acoustic tagging check out this awesome
example that involves smacking these 3d
printed piggies artistic poster design
also opens up possibilities for TV
applications in this acoustic dining
example we always - tapping sound three
piggies the three sets of frequencies
taps each piggy filter sounds
differently so that our iPhone app to
detect identify each
to go one step further we demonstrate
the ability to encode a bit string
pattern making use of the fact that the
iPhone is both the speaker microphone
the bottom we modulate the input white
noise encode different bit patterns
if you feel like improving your Kongfu
in math there are tons of goodies such
as transmission matrices the Helmholtz
equation oh my the paper and the torque
slides are amazingly well written and
yes you should definitely have a look at
them let us know in the comment section
if you have some ideas for possible
applications beyond these ones we love
to read your take on these works thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time
you